in the video game industry there's
always something else for gamers to play
and new games risk losing their player
bases almost as soon as they get them a
fact these games found out the hard way
here are the hotly anticipated games
that lost most of their player base in
just a few short months Tom Clancy's the
division EB softs a much-anticipated
third-person shooter the division
launched a critical acclaim in March
2016 by June only three months later the
game had lost a 93 percent of its player
base falling from 2.1 million players
per day to a mere 143 thousand while the
online shooter was by no means a bad
game the division had its fair share of
problems matchmaking issues and stat
bugs a stunted gameplay with cheating
and hacking plaguing the dark zone these
days the division is all but dead with
less than 3% of the game's launch window
Peaks still playing it's tough to
imagine Ubisoft feeling too bad about
the drop-off in players however seeing
as they raked in three hundred and
thirty million dollars in five days for
honor hitting shelves in February 2017
Ubisoft Verano promised explosive player
versus player combat with gamers able to
fight as either Knights samurai or
Vikings in a medieval setting sounds
incredible right like many games from
the top-tier French developer for honor
looked and in many ways was awesome
unfortunately severe technical issues
rewarded Ubisoft with a 95 percent
reduction and the game's player base in
only three months in a game that's all
about thinking ahead and executing quick
reactions Ubisoft decision to run for
Honor over a peer-to-peer connection
completely ruin the experience players
who bought for honor at launch were
seriously disappointed and even
organized a boycott of the game nobody
wants to see a game fail but
unfortunately for honor just couldn't
keep players interested no man's sky
this game promised at all some 18 quin
trillion planets nearly unlimited
exploration epic battles and space
dinosaurs so what went wrong well it
turns out that the infinite reaches of
space can be kind of
waring lemansky peaked on launch day
grabbing upwards of two hundred and
twelve thousand concurrent players on
steam less than a week later 78 percent
of those who gave hello games
space-exploration title a shot simply
gave up not even two four months later
no man's sky was seeing less than a
thousand players per hour resulting in a
94 percent drop in only 42 days Street
Fighter 5 launched in February 2016
Street Fighter 5 was supposed to be a
major console exclusive for PlayStation
4
sadly the vast majority of players who
picked up the famous fighting game
tapped out and tucked out quickly
plaguing the launch of Capcom's title
was too stark lack of content and no
arcade mode the bread and butter of the
street fighter franchise even worse
rampant ragequitting soured gamers
experience in multiplayer matches
quitters ultimately got what was coming
to them but the early damage was done
the poor experience was enough to put
over 75% of players of the game and most
people who left Street Fighter 5 never
returned Resident Evil 7 biohazard
admittedly most people put down
single-player only games after they've
beaten the main story nevertheless
Resident Evil 7 saw 90% of its player
base at disappear after only one month
on the markets at the games peak it
averaged roughly 15,000 players per hour
on Steam one month later that number has
dwindled to 1500 per hour rapidly
declining player base aside Resident
Evil 7 was a pretty big success for the
franchise with launch numbers doubling
vats of Resident Evil 6 and with the
game being received well by both critics
and fans alike till at its best
Resident Evil 7 topped out at number 19
on Steve's charts and to shareholders
apparently weren't impressed fortunately
none of that looks like it's putting a
damper on Resident Evil 8 evolve it only
took a 1 month for 2k games multiplayer
centric evolved to feel the pressure of
a rapidly declining player base not only
did the game received mixed reviews but
it's expensive DLC package certainly
didn't leave a good taste in any gamers
Mouse the game saw its player base
dwindle on almost a daily basis steadily
decreasing until turtle rocks to
had no choice but to swallow their pride
and to make the game free-to-play a last
resort for a game that released at full
retail making the game cost that nothing
effectively injected some life into the
title but the booze that didn't last
longer and he'll find yourself sitting
in a matchmaking Lobby for a long time
these days battleborn gearbox software
the studio behind the popular
borderlands series poured more than two
years worth of resources into the
creation of battleborn
only to have their first two-person game
completely overshadowed by blizzards
outstanding overwatch battleborn had
such a rough launch in fact that the
game only saw an abysmal 12000 101
concurrent players on release day and
absolutely plummeted in the days and
weeks that followed in a desperate
attempt to keep the game alive
the developers have made the game
essentially free to play sometimes a
stars just don't align Pokemon go my
antics mobile app Pokemon go it took the
world by storm when it launched in July
2016 by September however the game was
all but abandoned according to reports
Pokemon go peaked on July 13 2016 with a
twenty eight point five million users in
the United States alone nearly nine
million of those users quit playing by
the end of the month by the following
month almost two-thirds of the apps peak
users decided they'd had enough of the
craze nevertheless Niantic had a major
hit on their hands proving that the
Pokemon brand is as viable as ever Titan
4 released just a few months after the
Xbox one respawns first iteration in the
titanfall series was slated to be the
first true next-gen title sadly the game
was hamstrung by content and saw its
player base dropped off quickly the
biggest problem was that titanfall
wasn't just an online shooter it was for
all intents and purposes an online-only
first-person shooter lacking a
single-player campaign or any content
for users not looking to play the same
multiplayer matches day in and day out
plus being an xbox one exclusive
severely limited the player base to
begin with and many of the consoles
gamers moved on quickly to other titles
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]